[MUSIC PLAYING]
Yo, hold up.
What?
Now that's some stupid
shit right there.
Ouch!
He's never going to
have any more trouble.
We didn't land on Plymouth Rock.
[APPLAUSE]
Asalamalakim
Murder!
I have them.
You must be Black dynamite.
All in favor, raise your hand.
We he at?
Respect, if you can't
do that, then go.
Now get on back to work.
Demonstrate.
Resist.
They're going to
kill my children.
That means march, that
means disturb the peace.
Please.
He better come quick.
We ain't slaves no more.
I am loyal to the throne.
For the tribe!
What's up.
We are vegetarians.
And that's the truth Ruth.
Hello.
I am Ruth Carter costume
designer to the stars.
But I did start a long time
ago and when I was in college.
I decided that I wanted to
be a costume designer, when
I tried out for a play.
And I didn't make the
audition, so my teacher
who was the director
of the play asked me
if I wanted to do the costumes?
And I said yes, I
said yes because I
had been toying around with
the sewing machine in my room
as I grew up.
And I also loved to draw.
So I went to the
library and I looked up
what a costume designer does.
And it fit who I felt I was.
And so my journey began.
Here I am sitting
on stage in college.
I really loved being a thespian.
I enjoyed, I enjoyed
the stage so much.
I wanted to be an actress.
And I'm in rehearsal
here, probably not
Unlike some of you who enjoy
going through characterization.
And the artistic development of
a character finding their arc.
And immersing
yourself in character.
I believe that my work as an
artist in college, actually
really helped me quite
a bit to understand
the journey of an actor.
Here I am on the set
of Black Panther.
I'm standing next to the
director Ryan Coogler.
And we are examining M'Baku
the leader of the Jabari tribe
who is about to appear on
camera for the first time.
It's wonderful to be able to
present culture and character
in the form of costume design.
And M'Baku we will discover
through this lecture
how he came about with
our inspiration coming
from the Dogon tribe.
But here I am working away
in one of the many studios
that I put together for film.
And many times they're never
really big glamorous places.
They're cramped, small spaces
that we have to create in
and the environments
sometimes aren't optimum,
but what is consistent is
the love for storytelling.
And storytelling is
really the difference
between fashion and costume.
And costume is really the
art of creating a character
through garments,
but also the art
of creating a garment
that tells a story.
Many people think that I became
a costume designer because
of Dior, fashion
design, Barbie, but it
was none of those things.
Actually it was James
Baldwin, Lorraine Hansberry,
Sonia Sanchez, Nikki Giovanni,
those were my mentors.
Those were my inspirations.
Their stories told such
vivid tales of Black culture.
I was enthralled by them.
And I really wanted to bring
these characters to life.
One day in the 1980s--
and 1987 I met a
guy named Spike Lee.
And he called me early one
morning and he said "Ruth?"
"Hello?"
"Ruth?"
"RUTH" "Yes?"
"This is the man of your
dreams" I said "Denzel?"
He said "No.
This is Spike Lee, and I want
you to do my next film school
days."
So I moved to
Brooklyn, New York.
And I started to
design and create
the costumes for my
first film school days.
Now I had done so much theater.
I knew how to create characters.
I knew the character arcs.
But I had never built
this many costumes.
And these many
characters before.
So it was a big task for me.
And I cherish the experience.
And this is one of our
sketches from school days.
I went to my brother
who is an artist
and I asked him how to move
through these characters
on campus?
How to move through the
actual design process
as quickly as possible?
And he guided my
artistic presentation.
I went on to do so many
films with Spike Lee,
do the right thing where we
use the commutative of Brooklyn
to portray the protest
film to do the right thing.
And all of the elements.
This is the late Bill Nunn
who is wearing a big star
or die t-shirt, that we had
painted by a local artist.
So it meant a lot to us
to involve the community,
in our community story.
I also did the life
story of Tina Turner.
And worked with Angela
Bassett quite a bit.
And telling that
story with Angela
was a memory I'll never forget.
Because she immersed
herself in character.
And I immersed myself
in costume design.
I went on to design the story
of Malcolm X. And on Malcolm X
I received an Oscar nomination.
And this was a transformation
for Denzel Washington, who
went from a ballroom
dancer, wearing zoot suits
to a national speaker.
And it was really
important for us
to portray his life as
honestly, and as authentically,
as we could.
We had purpose when
we did our research.
And we went through
this process.
I also did a film
called Amistad.
And that was directed
by Steven Spielberg.
It told the story of
the Amistad Africans
who were on one of
the last ships that
sailed from Africa to Virginia.
And they took over the ship.
And it was a long court case.
But I really wanted to
show them in their native,
in their true sense, because
they were not slaves.
They were Africans.
So I looked up the culture
and I saw that many of them
would have been Muslim.
So we wrapped their
hair, and we gave them
I felt things that
would tell us more
about where they came from.
And moving on it
was 10 years maybe
more I think 20 years
later that I won the Oscar
for Black Panther.
So I want to take you a little
bit through that journey.
We created Wakanda.
And I'm sure many of
you have heard of it?
It sounds a little like
Uganda, but it's not Uganda,
it's Wakanda.
And there it sits in the
northern part of Africa.
It's right there East
of Mali, and North
of Nigeria, South of Libya.
But I have to tell
you one true fact,
and that is it doesn't exist.
You can't take a plane
there, you can't go there,
it doesn't exist.
But it was made up by
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
back in the 1960s when there
was a lot of civil unrest.
The Civil rights
movement was in effect.
And they felt like they
wanted to create a superhero
for the Black community.
So how did we come up with
the stories of Wakanda?
How did we come up with
the people of Wakanda?
Well, we studied so many
of the wonderful tribes
throughout Africa.
There's thousands of them.
And we picked just a few to
be inspired by our tribes
in Africa, in Wakanda.
And we gave them names.
One would be the border tribe.
And they were inspired
by the Lesotho people
of South Africa who wear
the wonderful blankets,
and the heart shaped hats.
And they are some of this
Wakanda's best warriors.
And the first line of defense
against the outside world.
Here they are in their
beautiful blankets that
were given to them by the King.
Well, our director
felt that he wanted
to use these blankets
in a special way.
And in that way he
wanted to create
a shield out of these
blankets by putting vibranium
on one side.
How many of you have
heard of vibranium?
Well, we did some illustrations.
And in those illustrations we
showed different ways, in which
we could adorn those blankets.
And this illustration
is somewhat
of a community and a family.
We have our tribal
elder in the front,
our Queen Mother to his
right, our fierce warriors
on the ends, and the
general community.
But when we looked at
these illustrations,
we thought this doesn't look
like a forward thinking nation.
This looks like more ancient and
more as they were in the past.
And since we were creating a
forward, more modern Wakanda,
we decided to do more
illustrations that would
incorporate some new ideas.
And we did that with
all of the tribes
that we were inspired
by to tell the story.
Here we have the merchant tribe.
The merchant tribe is inspired
by the Tuareg of Mali.
And where you see that the
women do not cover their faces,
and the men do.
So that makes our tribal elder
here in the front a woman.
We did the same
exercise by showing
how modern the Tuareg or the
merchant tribe I should say
modernized their look.
And here's how it plays
out at the Warrior falls.
You see our tribal elder Connie
with her large filani earrings.
And she's standing next
to her fierce Warrior.
We did the same thing
with the mining tribe.
And they were inspired
by the Samburu
people of northern Kenya,
the Dinka of South Sudan,
the Himba of Namibia,
the Maasai of Kenya.
You see Shuri, the
Panthers little sister,
she's wearing beads and corsets
that we fashioned by the Dinka.
And here is how the miners
looked in our illustration.
We wanted to come up
with ways in which they
would be mining vibranium.
How many have you heard, have
you have heard of vibranium?
Yes, vibranium is the strongest
metal known in the world.
And it's only found, in
Wakanda - all made up.
But we have our tribal
elder in the middle.
And we have the Queen
Mother of the mining
tribe standing to his side.
Here's how it played out
at the Warrior falls.
Now we begin to mix
other tribal inspirations
into the idea of the miners.
And the miners wear
this vivid orange.
They also - Our
tribal elder also
wears a Himba style hairstyle.
And that's the Shea butter
and the rich clay soil
mixed and adorned in the hair.
Some people think
it's worn that way
as they put the shea butter on
their skin and on their bodies.
And people think it's
for antiseptic reasons,
because of long droughts.
Or to ward off mosquitoes.
It's none of those things.
It's just beauty.
They love the way
they look that way.
And I think it's outstanding.
Standing next to Connie
is her fierce Warrior
who's inspired by the Maasai.
Now if you follow
the comics, you'll
know that at tribal
council there is
a elder in a Maasai headdress.
Very large Maasai headdress.
And I was prepared to put
this look in tribal council.
But Ryan our director,
didn't want it there.
He actually wanted the man
with the lip plate instead.
So when we got to
Warrior falls, I
felt like there was an
opportunity for me to put
the Maasai headdress there.
So I went to Pier One
imports, and I bought
myself a beaded placemat.
And I cut a hole in it.
And then painted it
and we adorned it
with feathers, and fur, and
we got our Maasai headdress
in the film, for about 20 bucks.
Here is the Golden tribe.
And the Golden tribe
is inspired by the Zulu
tribe of South Africa.
The most powerful
tribe of Wakanda.
Their technology has
developed far ahead
of the rest of the world.
And it's the tribe
of the Royal family.
Here's how we started
our illustration
based on some of the tribal
customs, and celebratory looks.
We have our tribal elder
and our Queen Mother.
And then we modernized the
look, just so we could give them
a look where we're not showing
Wakanda as someplace that
doesn't move ahead.
Wakanda is a place that
moves forward and has
great technology.
The Artisian tribe.
The Artisian tribe were
inspired by the two Turkana
people of Kenya.
The most traditional
of all the tribes
responsible for pottery,
textiles, and the arts.
So how could you not use as
much of the beautiful beading
and artistry that surrounds
many places in Africa
to create this look
for these tribes?
And you notice we have also
added the modern looks.
There is the River tribe.
The River tribe was
based on the Tsamai
and the Suri of Ethiopia,
and the Wagenya of The Congo.
So we combined many inspirations
from around the central and
southern part of Africa.
And we really did love the
look of the Suri children,
and how they playfully adorn
their hair and their faces.
We also modernized and took
a few artistic liberties
with the Wagenya look.
And the stick
fighters I was just
enthralled by some of the ways
that they adorn themselves
with armor and in
really unique ways.
Nakia who is played by Lupita
Nyong'o is from the River
tribe.
We presented to looks for Nakia.
On your right see she's
inspired by the Hammer tribe.
With the skins that are
beaded and the cowrie shells
that go around the neck.
Really beautiful look.
And there on the
left you see Nakia
in a totally made
up costume that
does have many elements
from the Suri children.
And that's the one
we chose to create.
Here's how it played out
at the Warrior falls.
You see Nakia adorning
her Warrior look
based on the Suri children.
And next to her is her
tribal elder with complete
with his lip plate.
And his costume is
completely made up.
And so we get to
our Royal family.
And we see them all together
in a photograph like this.
We took this photograph
during shooting.
And it was the first time that
the whole cast got together
in one place in costume.
And this was an
exciting day for me.
I looked to my left
and to my right
and I wondered if
anybody else was excited
as I was about costume
design and storytelling.
In this photograph,
you see Zuri in purple.
And he is the tribal priest.
He is the high
priestess of Wakanda.
And he adorns many of
the tribal language
that we put in the costume.
He has mali, he has neck
rings, he has a tabard.
Next to Zuri is what W'kabi
the leader of the border tribe.
And he's adorning
the Lesotho blanket.
And his chest piece that
is made of vibranium.
Above W'kabi is Killmonger.
Killmonger who
returned to Wakanda
to defend his rightful,
rightful place to the throne.
Below Killmonger is Nakia.
Nakia with her ring
blades and her and she
is the fierce Warrior
of the River tribe.
Below Nakia is Okoye.
Okoye is the leader of the
Dora Milaje the general.
The highest ranking fighting
force, female fighting force
of Wakanda.
Below Okoye is Shuri -the little
sister of the Black Panther,
and the leader of the
Wakanda design group.
She actually designs the suit.
Above Shuri is queen Ramonda.
The Queen Mother of Wakanda.
And she's standing next to the
late great Chadwick Boseman,
as the Black Panther.
So let's quickly talk
about some costume design.
Here we have W'kabi in
his Lesotho blanket.
These are the illustrations
that are done for costume design
early in the process.
We present all of these
costumes to Marvel.
We present these sketches.
And they look
through them and they
decide, which costumes
they like the best
and which ones
we're going to make.
You can see on
W'kabi's blanket, we
have illustrated vibranium in
the form of letters and things
on the inside portion
of his blanket.
Here you see the
palace guards, you
see another design
for the Dora Milaje,
you see a design for Shuri.
Well, let's begin
Black Panther suit.
When I first saw the suit
that was presented in Captain
America Civil War, I thought to
myself, it was on a mannequin,
it was in my office just stiff.
And I thought this is
not what I expected
from this the Black
Panther costume.
I expect a little
bit more something.
And so I asked Chadwick
Boseman to come in my office
and put the suit on.
And he did.
And when he put on
that suit, and he
began to stretch and do his
karate stances, I was amazed.
It really had magic.
When he put on that and
that the mask and it became
the Black Panther, it was
no longer Chadwick Boseman.
I was in awe.
And then Chadwick
said well, you know
I can't breathe out of
my nose in this helmet.
And I can't lift my arm
above a certain height.
So I thought that
would never do.
So we went on to build
the Black Panther costume.
And we pay particular
attention to the areas
of the face and the helmet.
So that he could
actually breathe.
And he could actually
lift his arm.
It started with a
muscle sculpt where
we create the muscles for
the Black Panther suit.
We vacuform them.
And we paint them silver so
they represent vibranium.
But there was one
particular thing
that we did to the Panther
suit that was really special.
And that was we created
the surface texture
in the form of a triangle.
And for us the triangle was like
a sacred geometry of Africa.
It's a shape that you see
in so much of the artistry.
We called it the
Okavango triangle.
Named after the
long Okavango river.
And the triangle had a meaning
for us that was of the family.
The father, the
mother, and the child.
We also had to come up with
different ideas for King
T'Challa to wear as he moved
around the city of Wakanda
and ruled over Wakanda.
And so here we have
what was inspired
by the Nigerian senators suits.
And the Nigerian senator suit
has the wonderful embroidery
around the neck
and down the front.
It's usually a tunic and a
pair of very simple pants.
But we put the embroidery
around the tailcoat,
just to give him a little
bit more formality.
We also created the
crown for Queen Ramonda.
Not in the comics queen Rmonda
does where the Isicholo.
The Isicholo is
the married woman
to South African
married woman hat
as you see in red on your left.
So we created this design and
then we decided to 3D print it
So it would be perfect.
We needed the Queen's crown to
be a perfect sphere that maybe
had some folklore that the
center faced the North,
that the sides faced East-West.
And it really meant
a lot to me that we
would use this technology
that was forward
thinking for the queen.
We also 3D printed
her shoulder mantle.
Now the shoulder
mantle you see here
in the colors is how many
pieces are printed in the big 3D
printing machine.
And it comes to
us in many pieces.
And we take it to our workshop.
And we glue it together and
then we actually paint it.
So here's how it
looked in our film.
On your left you see she
was standing completely
in blue screen, but in
the movie on your right
see she's standing in Wakanda.
So I told you a little
bit about the blankets.
The blankets that came from the
Lesotho people of South Africa.
And how we printed
vibranium on one side.
And when Marvel saw these
blankets, they like them.
But they thought
they were too heavy.
And so at the last
minute, we had
to shave all the blankets
with a men's razor, just
to make them thinner.
And we had about 150 blankets.
Then we sent a
video to Marvel that
would show how these
blankets actually now
are thinner after
their shave and they
have their vibranium on them.
So they are shields.
And once they saw our video,
they approved the blankets.
The Dora Milaje, the
highest ranking female force
in Wakanda.
Dora Milaje means
the adorned ones.
And these young women are
the King's bodyguards.
Here's how we created
their costume.
On your right see the
costume illustration
that was done by Anthony
Francesco of the Marvel design
group.
On your left, you
see the comics.
And they're quite
different, their costumes
are quite different
in the comics.
And that's because Ryan
Coogler our director
really wanted them to be
seen seriously in uniform.
And all of their vitals covered,
because they're fighters.
Not cheerleaders
skirts, and bikini tops,
but actual costume
design that would
represent many areas of Africa.
So we started with the Maasai.
And I thought we need
to bring up the red.
We need to show this beautiful,
vibrant red of the Maasai.
And then we went to the Himba.
The Himba women who adorn
themselves with the shea
butter and the clay.
And they put it in their
hair and on their bodies.
And also they take
the cat skins,
and they stretch, and adorn the
cat skins, and create costumes.
We took all of those elements.
And we returned the illustration
that was done by Anthony.
We turned it forward.
We added all of these
elements to this costume
including beadwork.
And as you know bead work
is a very, very common
artistic element of Africa.
And has several meanings.
So this is how our
costume came about.
We created a tabard, we
created the Himba leather
that centered around the body
and honored the female form.
Also there was a back
skirt that the leather
was stretched and
adorned in the same way
that the Himba women do.
The Turkana tribe was our
inspiration for the beadwork.
And we also had scarification.
So we wanted to show
different ways, different ways
of showing beauty.
Scarification is
a form of beauty.
And we took the neck rings
and the shoulder armor
and we put a high sheen on them.
We plated them so they
would look like jewelry.
And this is a Okoye as the
Dora, the leader of the Dora.
So you see how you can
take culture and apply it
to a superhero model.
And that is called Afro future.
I mentioned in Mbaku who is the
fierce Warrior of the Jabari
tribe.
You might remember
him in the film.
And he says we are vegetarians.
Well, we wanted to honor him and
his character from the comics
in a beautiful way.
They honor the
silverback gorilla.
And then the comics
he has a gorilla
face that is very derogatory
and a sign of the times.
So we decided to give him
a more honorable costume.
And we put the silverback
fur on his back like a cape.
And the cape was
silvertipped a very hard
to stay on his shoulders.
We tried everything.
And the only thing that
would keep that cape up there
was refrigerator magnets.
And then once we put
the refrigerator magnets
and it stuck, it stayed and
it was very hard to get off.
But they are inspired
by the Dogan of Mali.
The Dogan.
They were one of the
first astronomers
and they have a celebration
to the solstice.
Once Ryan Coogler saw
images of their celebration
and their grass
skirts, he thought then
the Jabari should
wear grass skirts.
And this is how we started
our creation of the grass
skirt for Mbaku who was the
leader of the Jabari tribe.
We sent this video
to Ryan and to Marvel
to show how the grass
skirt would work.
And it was approved.
This is how it played
out at the Warrior falls.
Shuri who is this little
sister to T'challa
creates the Black Panther suit.
So she works in a lab.
And because of her youth
I did want her costume
to be like a lab coat
and boring, because she's
so young and so ingenious.
So we gave her overlays.
Most of her costumes
had wonderful overlays
like the organza sweater
you see on your left
and the sheer netting that
you see on your right.
And those were her
protective layers.
So we created Afro future with
the Black Panther costumes.
We took technology
and we infused it
in a superhero model.
And this is how it
all came together.
Thank you Ruth, so much for
that amazing presentation.
At this time we're going
to take a few questions
from some students.
In what part of the film process
does the costume designer
start to get involved with
the film production process?
It really depends
on what director,
what the director wants.
When I work with Spike Lee,
he sends me the script way
before we start our process.
He really wants me to start
thinking about these characters
early.
And so I feel like I'm
one of the first people
to get started right in line
with the production designer.
But on Black Panther, I was--
I came in to Marvel I've never
done a superhero film before.
And Marvel is like the CIA.
And everything is top secret.
And I met with Ryan Coogler
and Hannah Bechler and Met More
who was the producer and
the production designer.
So they were on
long before I was.
And as I walk into the office I
saw images all over the walls.
And I saw development in place.
And I really felt like
I needed to catch up.
So it's nice when you can
come on as early as possible.
Sometimes in independent
films you come on much earlier
than you might in a studio film.
OK.
What would you say
are some skills needed
for being a costumer
for film and television?
You have to be able to
imagine the characters
and see them in a way
that's achievable.
So if we said Oh, I'm imagining
these characters flying in
on a spaceship and getting
out and their costumes morph
into different things, you might
not be able to achieve that.
So when you read
your script, you're
thinking about you're
imagining this world.
And you're imagining it in a
way that you can achieve it.
And it's not to say
that you shouldn't think
outside the box,
and it shouldn't
bring innovative ideas into it.
Because maybe that
spaceship idea
morphs and changes
as you go along.
And as you read
your script again.
And as you start doing
your illustrations.
But at some point you
have to really take
imagination and research and
apply it to a real 3D form.
You've got to create
these characters.
And so I think imagination
is very important.
I agree, love that.
How did you, in the
film Black Panther,
how did you stay true
to the comic book
and true to the African
culture while you
were creating the movie?
Yes.
Well, the comics actually
did provide a free space,
a safe space.
Because when you
look at the comics,
you saw Masai you saw in the
Ndebele, you saw Turkana,
you saw all the tribes
of Africa represented.
So I was joyous when I
looked at the comics,
because it gave me an
entry to the creativity
that I was going to experience.
But they're little tiny
boxes, they're small boxes.
So you so detail is not there.
So you get a general
and broad sense,
but a good sense of what
will Wakanda should be like.
And so it was an
opportunity for me
when I applied it
to the costumes
to show all the majesty,
all the detail, all
the different areas.
It was like a love letter,
an open book to creativity.
Nice.
Can you explain a time that
you had to make a hard decision
or fight for your point of
view to be seen or heard?
Yes.
You have to trust your voice.
You have to feel
things in your heart.
But as artists sometimes
we have to let go,
because this is a
collaborative medium.
It's not that you're on
your own island doing
everything your way
and everybody else
is in a separate area.
We're really actually
collaborating.
And so if you open
your mind to things
that may not agree to what
you thought it would be,
actually you might
learn something.
You might learn something new.
And the new idea might
open up an avenue that's
even bigger than the first one.
So I always say be open to the
ideas of your collaborators,
because every time someone hears
a note, or they read a story,
or they listen to
what's going on,
each person will
interpret it differently,
each person will hear
something different.
So not getting your way or
not having your special idea
in the film is not terrible.
You can store it and
use it on another film,
or use it in another way.
But the collaboration is
a bigger payoff for you.
Nice.
What part of costuming
brings you the most joy?
I think, I get very
excited about culture.
And when I first started out
and I was doing Malcolm X.
I went to the Department
of Corrections,
and I got his files
where he was in prison
for a short time
of his life, where
it was a transition for him.
And I wanted to know more
about that transition.
And so I was excited to read
his letters that he wrote.
I saw his whole file
his whole history.
And it was firsthand from him.
It was like he was
telling me about his life.
Also on Amistad I wondered
how these Africans
from Sierra Leone how it was
what it was like for them
on that ship.
And so I had no other writings
except for the cargo list.
What was the ship carrying?
Because they were carrying
not only Africans,
they were carrying goods,
blankets, materials, food.
So when they mutinied the
ship will adorn themselves.
They're going to
put those blankets
on their bodies the way that
they would in their homeland.
It was we were already in
America, in the Eastern
seaboard, it was cold.
They would wrap their heads.
So that's how I told
their story and I
get very excited about
the research portion that
gives me a clue to the real
story, the truth of the story.
What could have really happened?
What would you say is your
greatest achievement thus
far for you?
My greatest achievement
thus far for me
is not only winning
the Oscar, but also
being told that people of
Africa loved Black Panther.
And I was representing their
culture in costume design,
and not being African
- of African descent.
And when we go through our
research in the history books,
it's so easy to misrepresent.
And so the accomplishment
of authentic representation
means the most to me.
Nice.
When creating Black
Panther, did you
get a chance to actually
visit the continent of Africa?
And if so, what
part did you visit?
Well, I went to Africa
after we shot Black Panther.
I researched the tribes
through the history books,
because we were
basing the costumes
on the ancient indigenous
tribal customs and technologies
that they were using.
And bringing it into
a superhero form.
So if I had actually
gone to Africa
to research all
of those details,
I'd still be there right now.
But I had known so much by
the end of Black Panther
when I did my vacation,
I went to Johannesburg
to the first Afropunk
celebration there.
I went to Cape Town and I just
laid back and enjoy myself.
And then I went up into the
bush on a private Safari.
And I immersed myself
again in the culture
and had a beautiful time.
I was there for like six weeks.
Nice, nice.
And this is going to
be our last question.
Are there any
resources, books, films,
that you would recommend
to a future costumer, that
would help them learn
storyboarding, character, tone,
and mood?
I think first there's
a couple of programs
that are good to learn one's
called Costume Plot Pro.
Another one is called Sync
On-set and those are tools.
As far as breaking
down costume design,
it's good to look
into costume books.
There's one called
Hollywood Costume.
There's another one
called What They Wore.
You can Google things
and get basic knowledge
of costume design.
But character, there's no
manual for the imagination that
is involved when
you're coming up
with a costume design
for a character.
There is no roadmap, it's
completely subjective.
It's whatever you
experienced in your life
and you think that this
character should be.
So I would read,
I would observe,
I would live your life,
and be a people person.
Understand what makes
people, make the decisions
that they make.
And what happens as they
go through their lives,
you really do have to love
people and their differences.
Awesome I would like to
thank you first hand for one,
being my mentor and thank
the Academy for matching us
together.
And having this
conversation with me.
So just thank you for your time.
Thank you LaShell.
I enjoyed taking you through
the creation of Black Panther.
And a little bit of my story.
And hopefully it will inspire
you to create costume design
for film.
I enjoy infusing African culture
into the superhero model.
I enjoy being a
messenger of authenticity
with tribal, culture,
and modern technology.
So good luck to you.
I wish you the best
and Wakanda forever.